[Musique]
c'est un projet mis en place donc ce
sont des ateliers champ et théâtre pour
les petits donc manicois ou non entre 7
et 14 ans donc c'est des sont des
ateliers qui prennent part qui prennent
place dans le festival à tout boutchamp
donc un festival qui a lieu chaque année
ici dans la commune donc un festival
pour toute la famille de autour de la
musique et donc ce projet il a pour but
vraiment de proposer aux enfants une
activité un peu
extrascolaire de les réunir
et vraiment voilà de les de former un
groupe donc c'est at des ateliers chant
et théâtre qui ont lieu chaque samedi à
partir du mois de janvier donc il y a
cinq ateliers en tout on a une semaine
de stage en février
et un spectacle au mois de mars donc
dans le cadre du festival à toutbout
Dechamp on a eu vraiment beaucoup de
demandes de la part des des familles et
des enfants c'est un projet qui plaît
beaucoup on a eu on a pas mal d'enfants
qui reviennent s'inscrire cette année
qui était déjà la l'année l'année
précédente donc du coup on a deux
groupes le spectacle on aura une
première partie avec le groupe 1 une
seconde partie avec le groupe 2 et en
final noralement qui qui rejoindra les
qui regroupera les deux groupes
ce spectacle se tiendra le 13 mars avec
deux représentations une à 15h et une
secondes à
17h